hello
good evening everyone um uh with us here
in space and online uh my name is
nicholas tamancho i'm head of the
department of architecture at mit and
i'm having this weird experience that
i've been having all week now of meeting
people in person for the first time that
i've only met on zoom over across the
last 15 months which is
frankly a great pleasure even as it's
tied up with all the strangeness of the
time we're living through our ability to
be with each other tonight in any way
is hard one
and it's the result of hard work on
behalf of
all members of our department uh
community but it also has that flavor
as i wrote to all of you last week of uh
queueing for a ride at disneyland a kind
of weird spatial theater where we're
trying to get back to something that
resembles the real true life of this
department and we're almost there but we
turn the corner and there's another half
hour wait so i i really really
appreciate uh
everyone's
cooperation in making this
hybrid occasion work tonight and in
sitting here with masks on and allowing
us to celebrate each other in the way
that we can
a condition of almost a rival is an
architectural one first and foremost
embedded in our own architectural
language are important lessons on how to
think about arrival and belonging the
the english word foyer has its origin in
the word actually for
this kind of vestibule that that you
enter in but also for hearth and home
and so
i think our task here this semester both
with all of you here and with all of you
watching us
online is to try and find each other and
to try and create a home in this space
of continuous not quite arrival
in this spirit we've convened our
lecture series our fall 2021 public
program a continuing set of
conversations as we wrote to you all on
where we are now
our events explore the department's home
at the intersection of design and
research with visionary symbolism
extraordinary mechanics decolonial
maneuvers new methods of computation
situated technologies and design
research
all at the foreground
we have spaceships in the desert
conversations on care
and
above all a belief in the enduring power
of defiant optimism
it is not to me to introduce our first
speaker tonight um sanford bakers but i
will give particular thanks and
introduction to brandon clifford the
director of our masters of architecture
program
for his
incredible and institutional help in
bringing sanford to us at mit not just
for tonight but for an entire year
to join this community and join the
community as of mit as a whole as one of
its
member of one of its most distinguished
programs the martin luther king visiting
scholars program so with that i give the
microphone over to brandon with care and
thanks and i'm going to do my mask
maneuver as well
and then we're going to make it happen
thank you nicholas
hello everyone
it is a real pleasure to be able to give
this introduction tonight
i'm here to introduce sanford biggers
but first sanford
we are
a very small school
driven to make a very big impact into
the world and this is a part of the
school we're having a conversation
tonight that's being broadcast out to
the rest of the school in the lawn we
saw that earlier
we are all very excited to have you here
and on behalf of the community i just
want to welcome you as a faculty member
of the mit department of architecture
okay so now for the audience
sanford biggers is a ghost
a specter
a vision
for those of you in the room who are
convinced that sanford is real
i assure you that he is not
sanford lives in a state of reality
that transcends time and culture
he acts as a collaborator with the past
by exploring topics that are all too
often overlooked
topics that range from cultural identity
to police brutality
it wouldn't shock me to hear sanford
stitching together concepts of
cryptocurrency
with spirituality
through his work
sanford manages to identify the
essential and latent concepts of our
time
he manages excuse me he manifests work
that evoke visceral
contemplative
and illuminated responses from the very
society he reflects
and for this work he has received
a fair amount of recognition
his work is held in permanent collection
at moma the met
the whitney the museum of contemporary
art in chicago
the walker center in minneapolis
the national museum of african american
history and culture
in washington dc
et cetera et cetera et cetera
his work has been on has been shown at
countless institutions from the menil
collection to tate modern the
metropolitan museum of art the ica
boston
the barnes foundation and many others
this year alone
samford opened a solo exhibition
entitled code switch at the bronx museum
it had 50
quilt-based works that are now on
exhibit at the california
african-american museum
in l.a
not only did he have this show but he
also debuted oracle
a monumental bronze chimera sculpture
along with many other multimedia works
exhibited throughout rockefeller center
so sanford has joined us here in the
department of architecture at mit
as the current dr martin luther king jr
visiting professor and scholar
this very prestigious position follows a
string of other awards and fellowships
including the define art award from the
savannah college of art and design a
guggenheim fellowship sanford is
currently the board president at the
sculpture center in new york and he was
inducted into the new york foundation
for the arts hall of fame
he has an american academy of arts and
letters award and in 2017
he was a visual arts fellow at the
american academy in rome
this is also known as the rome prize
that is where i met sanford along with
john oxendorf
and um this is important because
everything i've mentioned in this
introduction so far
has happened
since we met sanford
it was not that long ago it's amazing
uh so i think there are two ways of
reading this
one is that i have somehow had a
profound impact on samford's career
trajectory
or more likely the point i'm trying to
make here is that
writing an introduction to sanford
biggers
is an incredibly humbling experience and
has questioned my career at its core
so
if i go just a little bit deeper into
history
samford's work is featured at the
whitney biennial
as well as the historic freestyle
exhibition at the studio museum in
harlem
so all this is just to say that sanford
is an absolute titan of the art world
now the question is
why
is samford joining us here
at the school of architecture
well not only is he a devoted
artist but he's a devoted mentor and
teacher having served as the faculty at
columbia university and has a visiting
professor
of visual and environmental studies at
harvard
so here we are a school composed of a
variety of disciplines that surround
this elusive concept that we call
architecture
and um
what will inevitably be
what will inevitably become clear over
the course of this evening
is that while samford operates as a
conceptual artist
his creative approach is no way bound by
a single discipline
rather he thrives on provocative
transdisciplinary collaboration
and with all of this i have not even
gotten to the point of sharing that you
are the front man of moon medicine
so at this point everyone's getting
tired of my introduction and very
excited to hear from you samford so if
you can all join me in a warm welcome
the man the ghost the specter sanford
bakers
[Applause]
harriet tubman grew up as a slave in the
19th century
she was born and raised in the south
she had many jobs
one of them being a slave
she wanted to escape what she knew
[Music]
so
[Music]
he
polishes his suit and tie
his smile
is alive
the dice cast the metal forms they drunk
off the line
but little do
they realize
he's counting on time
he's ready
[Music]
blankets dry
by the day
there's life in their bed
scoffing at
the bourbon sun
that left them for dead
the coated quilt has given word
the train leaves tonight
they're ready
this is the
greatest game
this is the
escape
[Music]
[Music]
good evening
good evening
it's been a while
last time i saw people was what year and
a half two years ago or so i haven't
done one of these in quite some time
excuse me if i'm a little bit dusty
objects have power
in the 20th century marcel duchamp
took a trip to the congo and he made
this work
you don't see this in many collections
you don't see this in many institutions
but this is how ideas travel
there's a book called the hangman's
house
i was living in baltimore and they were
getting rid of books from one of the
libraries
and i happened to pick up hundreds of
them to make an installation but the one
that stuck with me was this one not
because of the content but because of
the title the hangman's house
and i was obsessed at that moment with
the history of lynching in the u.s
um it sounds like pretty morbid thing to
be obsessed with but it's not quite
history it's actually our present
it's our continuum
so when i found this book i wanted to
give it its own ritual
many of you are familiar with in kissy
and various objects that you might find
at an encyclopedic museum that are
embedded with nails and shards of glass
and mirror
you see these frequently in various
societies throughout africa
and one of the ideas is that you could
turn an object into a talisman or even
a spiritual guard
that warns intruders within that
community
that that that group of people is very
they're very powerful and
the amount of nails and accumulation of
those sharp objects dictates that
in this gesture i was hoping to somehow
ameliorate the history the pathology of
what happens here in our country
now what i'm not showing you is the
performance i would say i wouldn't even
call it a performance but documentations
of putting these objects to use i took
these out into the suburbs of chicago i
was at that time a graduate student at
the art institute of chicago
and i wanted to figure out a way to
give work a patina
not just found objects that you can find
that already have a certain use patina
already on them but to embed them with
something more personal more actualized
by me the maker
so i went out to the suburbs around 6 am
i wore a suit and tie i sat at a lunch
counter along with several other
commuting businessmen who had their
newspapers and briefcases
and i held this as my newspaper
and the duchamp and the congo piece was
my briefcase
and of course i got strange looks at the
uh the diner but then i walked out and
got on the commuter train where i got
even more strange looks and it was a
crowded morning so i had to walk up and
down the aisles a few times before i can
find a vacancy
and when i finally found one by this
diminutive older
woman
blue-haired reading spectacles buried
into a book i sat down with this
you know gnarly book and the suitcase
and she looked at me and just dropped
her glasses a little bit and said is
that an in kissy
and i was shocked
turns out she was a docent at one of the
museums and she worked in the african
section
out of all the hundreds of people on
that train this is the woman who i sat
by and she spoke about all these various
objects from different societies with a
great deal of zeal enthusiasm and
knowledge
and once again i realized that nothing
really happens by accident so as i'm
trying to imbue these with some type of
experience i in turn receive this
experience that
shows me that the world is not as
close-minded as you may think sometimes
you just really gotta dig deep and find
the people who have open minds
so
imbuing objects um around that same time
i started to make mandala
floor pieces
partly influenced by carl andre
partially influenced by the three years
i'd spent living in japan and
going to different
temples and seated meditation guided
meditation that i received from monks in
japan
and i came back to the u.s and wanted to
make work that was autobiographical but
not featuring my body or a body for the
most part
so this was one of those first projects
this is around 16 feet by 16 feet
and as you see is hand cut rubber tiles
that are configured to look like a
mandala but once again to imbue this and
charge this with some type of uh
let's say um
performative or actionable type of
intent
i took this to various contests
throughout chicago in new york city
and i put a video video camera above
them and started to record breakdancers
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
autobiographical in the sense that i
grew up with all the hip-hop arts break
dancing rapping graffiti and djing um i
was never a good rapper but i was good
at the other stuff um and i got busted
for doing graffiti on the side of a
building in los angeles when i was
around 15.
and the cops
they were nice
i wasn't arrested i was held my parents
came in everyone scared the life out of
me and the next day i enrolled in apr
classes
so that started my formal education as a
an artist
um this event right here this project
right here i think you know as
interesting as it is to me in terms of
fusing aspects of art history and
performance
it's really a testimony to not trying to
fit tightly to any one specific genre
within that industry or in that field
so
this specific piece when it's exhibited
is usually put on the floor in a silent
room on an adjacent wall there's a very
small monitor and when i say small i'm
talking two by three inches embedded
inside the actual wall so you don't even
know that it's there unless you really
look around the main experience is
getting on the dance floor yourself and
you're prompted to do so because you see
all the scuff marks that are circling
and and demarcated on the floor it
accumulates a lot of stuff and to me
that's the use patina that shows what
its function is
when you finally find that monitor you
are then sort of in between being
minuscule when you're on the dance floor
and gigantic when you're looking at the
small monitor
and you know essentially i think like
many artists are it was an attempt in
making some type of a lo-fi transcendent
experience
and also
to break down some of the
curatorial and institutional issues
within museums at the time
because whenever this is shown whether
it be in japan or paris or somewhere in
germany or in new york city or wherever
it might be
a few hours per week people are invited
to come in and dance on the floor so it
separates that boundary between art that
you can and cannot touch it makes
everybody a performer even the person
who just walks across it is now in
league with these same breakdancers
right here so
in some way it's a an attempt at
community building but also breaking
down some of the barriers um for people
that don't feel that they are welcomed
in these institutions not only are they
welcome to to see this they're actually
asked to participate
and it's biographical because you know
obviously me being a breakdancer and a
graffiti artist i return to some of
these forums a lot so what you're
looking at here is actually the sanskrit
symbol of om done in a graffiti style
and this one is made out of poured sand
so
each grain is put there in fact this is
a better image it shows you how the
process works at least my process i do
not follow the tibetan process i made my
own way of doing it
um and it is a curatorial nightmare
because most curators are scared that
anyone that people will walk through it
or it will disappear or that they put
all this money to have this thing done
and it's ephemeral
um i think that's also sort of
you know the fugitive aspect of what i
do
um and even more interesting than that
is sometimes you would just come to the
gallery and you'll see
mouse tracks
all the vermin that are there when
everyone's gone that traverse across
this
so i did a much larger one um in an
abandoned warehouse in new york city and
this one was 20 feet by 40 feet i think
the dimensions are incorrect on this one
so don't pay attention to that
24 by uh 40 feet
and this is
a rendition of a sixth century prayer
rug and this was also done fully in sand
and at the opening there was probably
two or three hundred people walking
around and at one point
um a little girl around six years old
freaked out and she ran right across it
i already took the pictures so i was
fine it's an ephemeral piece
most people don't believe it's even sand
until something like that happens where
they realize oh my god that thing could
just be disrupted by a sneeze
um and she was light enough where she
just left a couple of smudges and a
little footprint and instead of everyone
freaking out they actually applauded her
she cried and ran out totally
embarrassed
um but i'm telling you telling you this
story and for the people that saw this
show
at the end of the day that memory is
probably more poignant than the work
itself
so i think in addition to making things
i'm really trying to make experiences
experience that i can't control things
that live in other people as they
traverse experience
share stories
about these pieces in the future
um so i mentioned that i lived in japan
for three years and around a decade
after that i was invited back to do a
residency
and i did a project where i wanted to to
investigate transubstantiation
and to do that i took hip-hop jewelry
fat gold chains necklaces rings that i
got on 125th street and throughout the
bronx and harlem
and then again in tokyo i did the same
thing i bought a bunch of hip-hop
jewelry there
and i worked with a few different
artisans throughout tokyo to melt all of
that down into an alloy and then we
press these into what are called oring
in japanese but singing bowls
many of you have seen these you can rub
a mallet across the top and it starts to
make a very beautiful sound it's a
meditative device these are often seen
in small scale and home shrines
i think it comes from shinto originally
but also you find it throughout buddhism
and various other cultures
and then stamped on it it says literally
infon memory of hip-hop hip-hop
nissasugu i think this was around 2004
and i'm sure all of you remember when
nas came out with the album hip hop is
dead in 2005.
uh it's his birthday by the way i think
so i took that to a temple that i was
doing seated meditation with um with a
the head monk for around two months
and um i don't know how many of you are
very familiar with customs in japan but
i could not ask to do a performance
there
i could suggest that maybe it would be
nice to do a performance there to which
the monk was like ah we spent so much
time it would perhaps be nice for you to
do that
which was his way of saying yes
so
we set up a few of my bowls with a few
of the temples bowls and they had bulls
that went 200 300 years um you know back
and we did a bell ceremony which was
literally an improvised bell
chorus
and once again i don't know how many you
know japan well but improvisation is not
the highest thing on the list of things
to do in japan so it's very difficult to
get that to happen but i did it with a
diagram
and we were able to pull this off
and the final striking was the head monk
himself hitting the one that says hip
hop nisasaku
so
mandalas
i was still very much deep into
exploring these ideas of these symbols
from buddhism specifically and that
gradually went on to other societies and
different religions and actually trying
to find some syncretism between them all
and not to really point out their
differences but where at the core there
were similarities
in this case i'm taking the mandala and
i was commissioned to do a piece at the
reuben museum well first
let me take that back a little bit i was
commissioned to do a piece in kansas
city and that's where i originally made
this piece which would later be viewed
at a buddhist museum in new york city
and this is a lotus lotus blossom of
course
is a symbol of wholeness
purity transcendence
as it grows from the muck and mire to
become this beautiful blossom
and this particular lotus is hand etched
into glass
84 inches diameter
weighs around 600 pounds or so
and
it was later hung in the middle of a
circular stairwell at the reuben museum
but as you can see on that image on the
right was that the closer you get and
the more you can the closer you can see
the details of each petal you realize
that they're actually
um cross sections of slave ships and
these are from diagrams from
slavers who would show up the best way
to pack human cargo for efficiency
and for profit
and these particular this particular
lotus has over 6 000 hand carved pieces
in there
and then i was later commissioned by the
city of new york to do a large version
of that on the side of the eagle academy
for young men which is a school in the
bronx
and it was a battle to do this piece i
was selected and i had to propose this
and there was a lot of pushback because
of some of the demographic of that
school not wanting to own the fact that
there was slavery in the u.s which was
strange to me because this was not
really making any moral decision or
moral um
political notion about it it's just a
factual thing and i'm trying to make a
transcendent device but it was so much
pushback that it took around three or
four months longer to approve this than
most of the other projects in fact at
the end of the day i'm shocked that it
even happened but it's still there this
is 29 feet or close to 30 feet diameter
and steel on the side of the building
and i just have a little 29 foot sorry
picture of us making that at the studio
and i'm showing you some of this because
you'll see these motifs
they reoccur throughout a lot of my work
this is a print series that i did with
columbia university a few years ago
and that's more of a graphic depiction
of that and the idea when i made that in
the first place was to gradually start
to degrade it more and more so at the
end of the day it becomes almost like an
icon you do not see the detail of it but
you know what it stands for
and it's sort of like a never forget and
transcend those tribulations type of
message behind it
[Music]
this piece is called blossom and it's a
reconstructed piano that is turned into
a midi player piano and what you were
listening to is my version my own
rendition of the jazz standard strange
fruit
um which of course is about bodies
swinging in the southern breeze
and the tree that is uprooting the piano
is um a sculpted tree it's made out of
steel and zoo epoxy and resin and silk
leaves it comes apart in three or four
different pieces
and when it's fully constructed this is
sort of the scale and the impact it has
and you see the piano bench right in
front of it that is kicked over as if a
body might have been
lynched
and this was really a response to the
gina 6 incident that happened in
louisiana around 2007 2008
which started at a
relatively integrated school in
gina where one day a black student
wanted to sit with a group of white
students under the popular kid tree
and
ask the teacher if he could go sit there
the teacher of course said yes he goes
over and sits there a few minutes later
the white students start to leave the
next morning there's nooses hanging from
the tree
and this incident goes on for several
months until it culminates with a fight
between some white kids and black kids
in front of a convenience store the
white kids pull a gun
the black kids beat up the white kids
and take the gun the black kids get
arrested for stealing the gun
and some of them went to jail and then
that's when all the protesters started
to descend into gina
so once again you know recurring motifs
and i made this piece i think this was
2007 when it was made
and up
very very high above is another piece
called cheshire which is a cheshire grin
once again this is a dichotomous piece
of course
i originally made that piece when i was
doing a residency in stuttgart germany
and i hung that in the black forest
and with the reference of cheshire
everyone of course thought louis carroll
alice in wonderland
i showed the same piece in richmond
virginia and everyone immediately
thought blackface menstrual c
and
that's a very interesting point to me
that the same exact symbol could hold so
much
specific gravity depending on the
context and the viewership
and that brings us to a series of
paintings that i've been working on for
the last decade or so
and this is called the codex series and
it started when i was doing an
installation in philadelphia where
artists were asked to re-envision some
very historic
buildings
residences
and
i'm sorry
yes people were asked to re-envision
some historic places throughout
philadelphia that had gone to disrepair
and basically forgotten
and i chose the mother bethel church
which was a very important spot um stop
along the underground railroad and i was
originally going to do an installation
that involved stained glass but for some
reason when i was in philadelphia i kept
being shown different places and there
were all these quilt exhibitions and
then i read about this
rumored
um
past that history that quilts were used
as signposts along the underground
railroad and potentially people were
getting map directions and hidden
messages through the codes or the
combinations of symbols or the colors on
the quilt or the way it might have been
hung or draped outside of a home
historians have debated that if it's
true or not for many many years but as
vernacular history and
it held enough interest for me to start
considering myself a late contributor of
code
along these inside embedded in these
quilts
so
while i was there too i also kept seeing
the image of gordon the slave and this
is also a very famous image
it's in the library of congress it's
used many many times this was um used by
abolitionists to show the atrocities of
slavery
gordon was an escaped slave who
apparently as the story goes would put
onions in his pocket so as he was
escaping he would rub his body down with
onions so the dogs wouldn't find him and
after he would swim through water every
time he got out he'd refresh the onions
so no so dogs couldn't find him and he
finally made his way to a union army
camp
and
later joined the union army and fought a
few times apparently there's a movie i
just found this out like three days ago
apparently will smith is making a movie
about this so
we'll see how that goes but anyway i was
fascinated by the scarification on the
back and how that started to remind me
of star charts
and i started thinking deeper about that
and made a map an overhead map of
philadelphia where i started to make
um
find the areas where official
underground railroad stops and
underground railroad stations were
throughout philadelphia and i made this
star chart this map
of them and if you went to those various
locations so part of my installation it
started a mother bethel but i had
little lotus
right there little lotus watches made
and i left them at all those locations
so if you made yourself if you got all
the way around the city to all those
locations you can pick these up and then
use them however you wanted to
and then
also i started making constellations
from those scars on gordon's back and of
course these are heavily abstracted at
this point but what you're looking at
are the codes so this is sort of the
star the constellation that's made from
some of the scars you see footprints in
there that imply you know travel escape
and of course the lotus
and that was the first one i did
and it was for conceptual insulation
basically but i found myself being more
and more drawn to these these as found
objects but also as canvases and i had a
studio visit where a collector on her
way out
said that she used to sell quilts and
she hadn't in many years so they were
just gathering moth holes in her closet
and she asked me if i wanted some and
she gave me basically 30 different
quilts
and that's when i started this practice
of painting on them
so over the years i've developed all
kinds of symbols to put on them i work
with any material i find tar
glitter oil acrylic spray paint
charcoal
burnt cork
you name it this one you can see the
cheshire grin on its side throughout the
whole piece
this one has tar glitter and assorted
fabrics
this one has a two-tone sequins that i
put on there and then i draw directly
into the sequins to create the tumbling
block effect
and again from that print series from
columbia you see the silhouette of
gordon
on the side so once again recurring
motifs and although i haven't spoken
much about music yet i will at some
point but a lot of my practice derives
some of its directives from
themes and music and recurring themes
variations on themes motifs and choruses
i think there's visual counterpoints to
that
but you know also you can see in some of
the quilt paintings that i'm also
pushing trump loy and perspective and
for me the logical progression was then
to start making three-dimensional
objects from that so what you're looking
at right here is what i basically call a
hyper object but it is a
three-dimensional wooden plywood
armature that has different pieces of
quilt mounted to it
that's a straight ahead view
that's a side view
and that gives you an idea of the scale
and i'm just going to rush through a few
images this is from my solo exhibition
that started at the bronx museum as
brandon mentioned and is now on view in
los angeles
um
this was the first iteration so this
opened in september last year and went
to april
and the quilt that you're looking at i
don't have a detail of that
but those two white marks in the center
are actually cut out from the quilt so
that's another
um
part of the exploration is now literally
using the negative space and then
pushing ideas of illusion optical
illusion and perspective and trump
lawyer
and these are several this is the
iteration now that's at um in los
angeles
and this was a particularly meaningful
place for me to show because this is the
museum that i used to go for saturday
art classes after i got busted for doing
graffiti
and in the corner you see a very large
version of one of the three dimensional
quilts that one is called kubrick's rube
i think we have some more details coming
up but
and also in well in the iteration at the
bronx you see the projected image of
that mandala dance floor
that is right there on the floor there
that was
also a nod to the fact that the first
museum that showed that dance floor was
also the bronx museum in 2003 or 2004 in
a group exhibition
and not only that
the film footage that you saw was from a
break dance competition that happened in
the bronx at the bronx community college
and i worked on those floor pieces for
around five or six years the sand pieces
and the dance floors until it ruined my
knees and i could no longer do it and i
stopped making that kind of work
altogether until i got to the quilts and
that's where the sacred geometry and the
patterning came back into the work so i
consider those to be totally related
and
you notice that i don't really use the
figure all that much i show ghosts
inspectors i don't really show full
figures
[Music]
and there's a lot of reasons for that we
can go into maybe in the q a um but
i realized that i was actually dealing
with the figure when i started dealing
with quilts because the figure is always
implied
and not only are the quilts
two-dimensional objects they are
performative objects because their first
purpose is to comfort and keep people
warm so even without the body being
present the body's implied
and that performative aspect is implied
um and then you know more reactionary
work happens through all of that and i
started to feel a little bit more
agency with using the figure again
and i started the bam series
and for this series of work i was
basically taking um
figures from different
cultures throughout africa some of them
being really authentic
um
objects from as long as a hundred years
ago all the way to chotsky's all the way
to stuff that i might find in harlem on
125th street
and the whole idea is that all of the
figures at the end of the day have some
degree of of doubt they're dubious they
come from dubious origins
and this is something that led to my
tenure at the american academy in rome
was finding what the origins of a lot of
these figurative symbols ended meaning
for us
so after i would shoot those um i would
get the objects dip them in wax i would
take them to a shooting range and the
sculpting really was happening with guns
i was shooting them with nine
millimeters and 12 gauge shotguns and
22s and 45s and so on
and obviously each different caliber
leaves a different type of mark
and once i finished the shooting process
i would take the remnants and cast them
in bronze
and then i would name them after victims
of police brutality
and there's precedence for this type of
you know sort of you know grotesque work
um i was particularly interested in some
of de kooning's clam digger and head
series he did a bunch of bronzes that
were these really sort of disfigured
abstracted
forms
and
i know this is also very morbid i was
also very obsessed with the image of
emmett till after you know the
castration and beating and after they
found his body bloated after being put
in the bottom of a river
and all this was coming together in this
body of work for me
so i'm just going to zoom through a
couple of different images from that
series
and
i sometimes just show the single videos
of you know the singular object being
shot but then i started to make
compositions from the videos that were
video standalone video pieces like this
so these are what five video monitors on
their side and there's a choreography
between how the imagery displays on each
monitor so for example you might see the
bullet coming in from the left and shoot
all the way across all the monitors
through the right so each one has a
different channel so the action is
different so it becomes almost a very
choreographed experience to see this
work
and then at one point i was commissioned
by the equal justice initiative which is
a new museum that's dedicated to
the history of incarceration and
abduction from africa that brian
stevenson opened up a few years ago
and this is literally the final object
you see as you make your way through the
entire museum this is what leads you out
the door
um
and this is a nine foot version of it
with the monitor on the side showing its
process
and then i started working in marble
and this is
obviously very influenced by my time in
rome and i started a series of works
that are called the chimera series and
these are hybrid forms that come from
greco-roman objects neoclassical objects
and african objects
once again all of these are from dubious
origins because as i would start to
research
various
uh sort of um
canonical works throughout europe i
realized that so many of them were
reproductions and then not only were
there reproductions they were new works
they were based off of poses from the
supposed classics and not only that a
lot of those pieces that we see today
and think of as eternally monochromatic
white pieces were often painted and
colored various with different pigments
so the only reason we know them as
alabaster white or monochromatic white
is because of weathering and time
and that made me think also the fact
that i'd never seen an african object
done in marble i've seen them in bronze
and wood but never marbles so there was
a bit of curiosity there too so i
started to create these chimera which
are they're monsters of sorts they are
the monsters of uh
of hybridized culture of history of
pathology of all of those things but at
the same time they're very beautiful
and the deeper i get into the product
the process i realize that it goes back
to one of the most important aspects of
sculpture in the first place and that's
just gesture and how the body and the
attitude of each of these forms convey
different ideas
and also i think this goes back to you
know being a child of hip-hop and rap
music and sampling and cutting and
pasting and chopping and screwing and
all of those different processes that we
take for granted these days but
it became a mode of production for me
oh i didn't give you any names i'm sorry
let me go back a few this one is called
a love supreme
um
i can't remember the name of this one
oh la
my french is horrible l-e-r-o-i
the king
but
anglicize it's leroy
this one is called the caress
and this is from a show uh towards the
end of last year at mary amboski gallery
in new york city
and many of you probably recognize those
four central columns as part of the
athenian acropolis
and
this particular piece they are cut out
and now lying flaccid on the floor
and
if i remember correctly my proposal to
go to the american academy in rome was
about the fall of empire
and looking at these objects as ways of
signifying various falls of empire
and this one obviously
from those rigid forms become these
flaccid ruins and it's flanked by two
other marble pieces
the ascendant
and
canegula
oh humor happens too
um the quilt piece up there on the side
is called the charlatan
and you've already seen this one
and this is where i first showed the
kubrick's kubrick's rube piece that
later
moved to the los angeles show
so i'm going to run through a few very
quickly this right here was the first
time that one of the marbles in the
bronzes actually were shown together
and i would love to do a show strictly
with marbles and bronze bronzes because
i think there's an incredible dialogue
that's happening with these works now
um this stuff is very fresh and i've
never spoken about this publicly so i'm
still formulating thoughts on some of
this and i do not want to
say anything that is untrue to these
and
though this isn't the most recent piece
this is one of the most recent major
installations of course this is oracle
and this was at rockefeller center
from may to
mid-july
and
this is 30 feet
well the bronze itself is 25 feet but
it's on a foot riser so ultimately a
thirty foot piece
and you can sort of see how that scale
is operating amongst the tall buildings
there
there's a few different
views of that piece
and this is the largest chimera i've
done and it's the only chimera that
exists in bronze at this point
but what most people and you know there
this got a lot of coverage uh it went
pretty viral online in terms of uh the
coverage of the piece and the press
coverage of it but a lot of people don't
realize that this was merely one part of
a 17-piece installation throughout the
entire plaza at rockefeller center which
included the flags that go around the
skating rink
and for those i did this uh installation
called sigaiha which are basically
um renditions of waves and water forms
that you see in mandalas tonkas
and um okua paintings and hiroshige
paintings
and i drew them and then smudged them
and scumbled them with an eraser and the
idea of having them up in a serial
installation was when the waves and when
the wind would blow the waves would
animate
and inside the building were several and
smaller installations these are three
chimera forms
and the backdrops of these forums are
video stills from a video project that i
did
in ethiopia and brazil
and i'm using those as the backdrop for
these forms creating the
i guess the landscape or or
the cosmic landscape that they might
land from
or hail from
and i also started engaging in virtual
reality for this project
there was a qr code that was
near each of the pieces and you can run
your phone by it
and
let's see i think
you could bring some of those objects
into the space
and they were monumental when they were
in the space
and
in all honesty that whole instillation
in rockefeller center to me was
basically part one of a much larger
installation
and i think the the virtual reality
aspect of that was a way of showing the
scale of how all of these objects might
exist in the real
campus that they may have come from
and throughout the various lobby were
different paintings
this is an exhibition that's still up
right now in
kinderhook new york
i have four pieces in that show
one of them is this
this almost mural-sized quilt piece
that's called slim slim is actually the
nickname of trayvon martin and this is a
portrait that i made of trayvon
from the police photograph of his body
laying down on the lawn after he was
killed
but in this case of course i flipped it
up and now he's ascending
and another marble piece that's also in
that exhibition called god whistle
and i'm not going to say much about it
but as brandon alluded to i am the lead
of a group called moon medicine
that is a conceptual band we do
performances wearing full costume and
masks with video as a huge component of
it in the back
and this is us playing at lincoln center
[Music]
dance
dance
sucker
meet me on the equinox
barbie dance
[Music]
so much blue
so much beauty so much used and misused
and abused
[Music]
so we dance
you the type to make slaves
we the type to freedom
[Music]
we dance
changing faces every night we call them
how we see them
so we dance
dance sucker
[Music]
we dance
on the equinox
yes
[Music]
you ain't never had to suffer
you ain't felt that strain
daddy bought your life it came with your
last name
yet you partying and drinking trying to
kill the planet
so you dance
[Music]
do
[Music]
the rhythm is living
we
yes we dance
some dance for chickens
[Music]
dance
[ __ ]
[Music]
and quit expecting me to jump every time
your fingers snap
what's elevated to your ranks is really
just a trap
nah baby we had to go to school to learn
that so we bought into the pipe dream
now we want our money back
[Music]
so we dance
[Music]
meet me on the equinox
[Music]
we danced
[Music]
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
open up your mind and turn your opinion
off
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you so much samford i'll keep
my mask on you can take yours off
um can everyone hear me okay
good
it was incredible so
there's something that caught my
attention where you paused
to speak about the new work
and
i understand tonight you were you were
sharing a bit of um
you know you gave us a bit of the hits
some of the new work you're giving us a
kind of life's work up until today
and i just want to reflect a bit as
people are thinking of their own
questions to be passing up here
how you make decisions about when you
move from a series to these cataclysmic
shifts
like we see things like the lotus work
popping up again and again we see it in
a series like a linear series where
you've crafted that series together
and then it might disappear and then you
have a cataclysmic shift where you move
into the chimera series
and i wouldn't be shocked to see
lotus somehow being embedded into one of
the chimeras so that's what i'm
wondering is like what is that capital p
project
how do you think about individual
projects series of projects and then
when you take that moment to shift from
media
um is it
is it possible okay
it's gonna be hard for you to see
but if you look at the throne that the
oracle is sitting on you see several
lotuses
going all the way across
so the idea is developing a language
that allows me to traverse different
materials and even different themes and
start pulling some of those
visual cues back into the work
it's a way of in some ways grounding the
work for me
but
it's not really planned out i'm
imagining 20 years 70 years from now if
i'm still here
to be able to look back at the work and
see how those ideas develop through
those signifiers
i don't consider anything to be totally
done
because the minute you move into a new
place it takes on a new meaning and and
you know it has the ability to be
malleable that way
but some of those elements that you see
that continue are a way of grounding
them and linking them together i think
um
yeah and i think that's what's so
powerful about the idea of the cheshire
is that depending on where it's
presented which culture an entirely
different meaning
would take place
um
so i'm kind of
i'm curious about if you can walk us
through the origins of these projects
because
what i'm seeing it as you have a
recurrence of these ideas and you're
exploring them sometimes you shift
medium but sometimes you just continue
to produce and produce and produce it
feels like you're seeking something
you're re we would use the term research
at mit like you're just after it and
you're going
this is very different from an idea of
having a concept and delivering one
piece and stepping away and it's off in
the world so this is like this continual
search that you have i'm wondering
how much of that is that you're after
something and how much is the work
surprising you in turn
it is
about the surprise um i think
part of that research is because you
know that you haven't really got to
whatever quote unquote the core is
and i don't really think i want to get
to the core i like
playing and experimenting around the
periphery of the core
i think it's for other people historians
writers to find cores for themselves
i don't want to be so prescriptive as to
say the work is about this and this is
the thing
it's really about the process and art
visual art is a place where you can
experiment and express in that way
because nothing is about isn't there's
no fact
i mean it's all true and lies and i
think that's sort of beautiful
you brought up
vernacular history earlier
and
i'm wondering what
your connection to truth is
because in in that moment
you're very open to the idea
that a history something that's written
down in the euro-centric model
becomes truth somehow that because we
write it down and someone verifies that
someone so wrote it down and then
someone else verifies that that that
becomes a societal truth and the
vernacular history to you seem to be
much more valuable oral histories and
that's where i'm wondering is like how
much does truth as a as a concept
i mean
are you seeking truth are you playing
with truth i mean i think the only truth
is the process that's sort of the point
um i think we're all witnessing a moment
where we're realizing that truth is open
source
and it's really who speaks the truth the
loudest or
you know proliferates our attention span
with their truth
trying to convince us that it is in fact
true
is a process that we're literally
watching happening on a day-to-day basis
um and we know there are some things
that are like immutable truths
i think
um like
um
well the sun
theoretically will come up again
tomorrow or at least the next day
that one we can work with right that's
probably going to happen there might be
a point where it doesn't
but for the foreseeable future that's
probably going to happen
now should we enter into buddhist
philosophy on truth here
well i know what do you think well well
no no continue i'm sorry i'm just
trying to get you going basically no but
i mean you know to some degree and yeah
this is a provocative statement i think
there is malleability and truth um and
there's malleability in history i think
they're both valuable constructs
um and time bears them out you know
there's things that you believe for 100
or 200 years and then all of a sudden
there's a societal chip or a shift or a
cultural shift and no one believes it
anymore um there's all kinds of examples
about that so you know i think when we
talk about truth and his truth when we
also you also have to put time into that
equation you know
i think some truths expire oh okay
yeah that's great so i just want to
transition to questions from the
audience i mean
one of the things that i was drawn by
your lecture is just
how many different ideas or it can be
extracted
so here we have one could you speak to
your next steps in your art
with regards to the african context
and references in your work
yeah i've been thinking about that a lot
um i find myself being
very more and more drawn to abstraction
and that
work that has the figure in it and that
has some degree of representation does
not negate the fact that it could also
still be abstract
and in fact what we're doing is
abstracting history abstracting visual
literacy abstracting truths we're
abstracting things all the time
and i guess
part of what i think the variety of my
body of work my project represents
is that i can use all of those aspects
whether it be from one particular group
in africa or one particular group in
europe or one particular group in the us
and start to conflate them all to see
how much gravity how much weight they
each hold or are they in fact
interchangeable to some degree i did a
piece when i was in college that was you
know admittedly a horrible piece but the
idea of the piece was that popular icons
do fall and this once again speaks to
that idea that over time things that we
believe wholeheartedly and somehow start
to dissipate
or potentially can dissipate and that
icons and images can do the same thing
like we're talking about the cheshire
and how the meaning shifts in different
contexts
so i'm curious and part of that is an
experiment to see
how much
the gravitas per image basically
yeah you you were talking a bit with
regard to figurative work
um you were talking a bit about spectres
and ghosts in the quilt pieces that are
somewhere in between figurative and the
sacred geometry that you're working with
and then when we get to the chimera
series
you become interested again in i guess
the foundation what someone might say is
the foundations of sculpture you're i
think you the word you were using was uh
gesture
um yeah gesture
so canonical and yeah various yeah i
guess it's not
it's never pure in the sense that you're
working exclusively through figurative
work that even when you're bringing in
figurative work from african sculpture
and blending it with european classical
sculpture you are
through that mix creating something new
i think it's abstracting both of them
okay that's really sort of the goal in
fact i've written about it and i find
myself
having a hard time with the linguistics
like classical european and
african works or classical european and
classical african works or traditional
european and traditional african works
what are the right descriptives why do
we not use classical african when we
know that some of these are also
canonical icons and forms that have been
in various cultures for
presumably hundreds of years there as
well so how do you start to change
and
grasp how we're putting hierarchical
import onto various cultures and not
other cultures and i want to conflate
all that in some of that chimera work
that's why i call them monsters too
because this is right
yes and well tonight i was learning
about how the research you were doing in
rome
that many of the sculptures are
reproductions of other sculptures copies
and that a lot of the pieces that you're
taking uh with the ballistic work with
bam for instance the question about what
is the authenticity or we can return to
truth about could you talk a little bit
about
um this this kind of cycle of the
african sculpture the tourism market and
then like
as we think about what
what would the original piece be
um well i think well that's a good
question because there is an artist
right now in nigeria who's making an
object for a tourist that's an authentic
african object that is an original
once again time is part of this equation
it's no less authentic because it's made
today than if it were made 100 years ago
and that same tourist market exists in
rome you can walk around and find
miniatures of everything that's out
there so this is a common sculptural
practice artistic practice commerce
practice and it's universal
um
yeah so i think my question is the wrong
question to be asking right
um here we have we have another question
so
this is getting to experience
and
which art piece that you have created
curated
the most memorable experience for you
this is a question about the peace
surprising you in turn
i think that's another reason i
experiment so much because i could say
many of them have experiences i have
anecdotes to almost all those works
i remember making the mandala the large
mandala and i've made six or seven
mandalas but that was the largest one
that was used for the dance floor i
remember specifically i was working with
my collaborator on that piece david
ellis
late late late late nights um you know
no sleep for you know a week type of
thing i remember deangelo was doing a
concert downtown new york and he never
plays anywhere and we had access to the
show but we had a deadline and we
couldn't make that show
but then we had to work in this little
warehouse shop that actually was across
the street from where he was practicing
so we were able to hear him practice for
that gig every night while we were
working so now it's more important to go
to work because we actually hear not
just the show but the mistakes the
outtakes the improv we hear all of that
stuff across the street
so you know that's one of my memories
for that and then of course being in the
bronx and seeing all those people there
for the actual show but you know i can
tell you anecdotes for almost all those
all the pieces
um the first time we saw a love supreme
the marble and that was just a few years
ago when it came to chicago and we
didn't know how heavy was going to be
what it was going to look like how big
it was really going to be in that space
you know the thing weighed 800 pounds
and like how we're going to move this
thing around
and then the first thing that the dealer
said was we need to charge more
nice i remember that
um anyway they all have stories they all
have lots of stories but um the moon
medicine stuff that is usually it comes
from a different place the experience is
very different it is ephemeral it's time
based it's improvisatory
i'm playing keys and piano in the group
if you guys couldn't tell by the visuals
but
those are the projects where i'm the
least in control even though i'm the
band leader and i select the setlist and
i co-write the music
i feel like i am the least in control
everybody up there are professionals
they make their money by playing music
and every time i'm up there i'm feeling
like they are permitting me to be on
that stage with them even though that's
not really the case but that's where i
feel like a novice and
and a student and it's thrilling
so let me ask you a little bit about
performance then
because i think that that's one of those
moments where you're you're talking
about
empowering an object
through the performance thinking of the
ankisi piece
on the train right
that instead of thinking of the
performance
as the work itself
that the performance becomes
either a way of charging the work this
is a word that you've used
or
the other
the other way that i'm curious about is
where you're making a piece and then a
performance follows it like for instance
the mandala
or the the girl walking across
that isn't
that would have been a surprise although
i'm sure you had it in your head but it
wasn't planned out right
so
the difference that i'm trying to
distinguish here is between
when you're intentionally making a
decision about a performance and when a
performance inherently happens to the
work itself where it gains its own life
and how much meaning does that have for
you
i
my answer to that is probably
influenced by one of my mentors
the late terry atkins
and it's
basic jazz fundamental and improvisation
fundamental
is that
i'm actually just creating instances
something's always going to happen
and
i don't know what to anticipate but i
anticipate that thing will happen
and
i
it's very hard to put this in words but
what i'm really doing is just setting up
the opportunity for the unknown to take
place
i think that is a very performative
thing and i think it's a vulnerable
thing but i think it's also
a um
an ecstatic
affair because you sort of know
something's going to happen i don't know
what it's gonna be this time i can't
wait for that thing to happen and then
it didn't have it inevitably does happen
the girl running across happened and it
was that
gas from the crowd i was like wow that
would be better than an hour long
performance you know just that six
second instance
um and i can't think of any
work of mine or
proper installation context where
something unexpected like that has
happened something has not happened
okay so uh i have another question here
so given the autobiographical nature of
your work
would you ever return to tagging
uh and they're continuing here to a
question about engaging with an audience
outside of a gallery or rockefeller
center uh signed graffiti kid from
jersey
great question um
yeah i would consider tagging again
there's a new way
not tagging in the tr
the classical sense of tagging
um
but
i think
there's an opportunity for a new type of
tagging and
um my friend from new jersey probably
has some ideas but considering the space
the cyberspace the where the world we
live in right now and our means to
um
distributing information and ideas
there's all kinds there's so many
different forms of tagging
a performative tag usually when moon
medicine does something related to an
exhibition or in a an official
institution or venue we usually go to a
very unofficial
late night bootleg spot and do an
improvised set
very much before after after
that's a tag in my way in a thought
because there's people who go to that
that would never have come to the first
part and vice versa there's some that
might go to both but very
the majority of the crowd at this spot
in the juke joint is very different than
the one that was over here at the ivory
tower
and i commend those who traverse between
but
i think that's a form of tagging yeah
public work is a tag always and then it
gets tagged on so you get you have to
deal with all that but
that that idea that you would start to
span different audiences that you're
you're shifting and moving
um
feels very open source to go back to
that context
okay so the next question is uh
would you say that pain
or violence play a large role in your
works
or perhaps might you categorize the
feelings and themes involved differently
i would categorize them differently i
think pain has influenced
memory history and in some degrees
reality so i would not ignore pain
but i don't think my work comes from a
place of fear and
sadness in fact i think it comes from a
place of
ecstasy
and critique sometimes
but
amongst that you know i think they're
myriad
feelings or or
ideas in the work pain is just one
violence happens
there's bodily violence but i think
there's artistic violence too and i'm a
big fan of that we're talking about
graffiti there's people who think
graffiti is violent whereas others find
it beautiful
taking a found quilt
and making marks on it is sacrilege to
some people am i defacing it or am i
embellishing it i actually really sort
of like straddling the line of all of
those things and not fitting into one of
them
i think that's another thing that's very
important right now um
particularly this is a really niche art
conversation there has been a huge
proliferation of artwork that's been
championed by african americans and
african and you know creators of color
um in general um people say it's
trending they're saying all these
various things but amongst that
the real thing i think you should look
for is tone
and the variety of tone you're seeing in
the work that people are
pushing towards you to say this is hot
and this is hot this is hot and you know
you don't want to i'm interested in
things that have tones that are
unfamiliar
i think a great artwork can make you
cringe if it can do that it's probably a
great artwork if it just makes you smile
and oh you know swipe left you know
whatever
well
that leads perfectly i've got to say
also thank you for the handwriting that
i'm receiving tonight it's very helpful
uh that's that's not sarcasm
they're
legible so this one has to do with
patina
a lot of your work acquires patina scuff
marks tracks bullet holes
tears rips
how do you see the transition to marble
and bronze in this context of objects
that transform over time
well i think the marble does show the
the trace of the hand if you get close
to the pieces they look super smooth but
you get close and you start to see
different
blemishes and things that i actually
sort of like because they add realism to
it
um and i don't want to uh spoil work
that might be happening in the future
but i was influenced by ruins and i've
yet to make ruins so that's a
possibility right um i
tend to construct a bit of a language or
a vocabulary only to deconstruct it
um so you might see deconstructions of
various types coming
all right
okay so i think we'll take one last
question from the audience before
treating you to a slightly cooler room
when constructing the quilts
have you ever had the inclination to
engage in a dialogue with your
grandfather's murals
um my grandfather's murals i'm assuming
john biggers
is that
who
grandfather's work under that assumption
since these are anonymous questions so
um john was actually a cousin
but if that's what we're talking about
um
i what i didn't show and you know what i
did a very large installation at mass
moca
in 2011
and i showed a quilt painting in the
upper mezzanine and i did a full-scale
reproduction of one of john bigger's
murals though it's called the quilting
party and john biger's work was a
mixture of figurative work and
sacred geometrical work figurative
geometry all this you know figurative
abstraction all this stuff was happening
in his murals
and i actually think his work influenced
me to do anything related to patterns in
geometry in the first place that
includes the breakdance floors and all
of that the mandalas i think that was
coming from the tradition set by john
biggers of using geometrical forms in
his artwork i wanted to find a way of
incorporating some of that language and
then putting my own spin on it no pun
intended with breakdancers but um
and then you know obviously that's gone
into the quilts and so on so they're
totally related and i'm glad somebody
asked that question because you guys are
really paying attention that's good okay
great
well thank you sanford i'm gonna pass
the mic to nicholas here i think we can
also in the meantime give a very warm
round of applause and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
so it falls to me to um uh conclude our
lecture tonight in the most important
way with thanks first and foremost to
sanford for an amazing
mind-blowing beginning to our journey
together for this year
i also want to thank if anyone's left
out there i want to thank our
architecture students
council or asc for the online for the
outdoor jumber tron they set up at their
picnic to allow
all of us to enjoy this lecture together
whether inside or outside
and then i also wanted to
give particular thanks in the context of
inside and outside
to the support and co-sponsorship of
this lecture by
the art culture and technology program
or art program that's lodged here within
our department
i think this
is part of our excitement and our entire
justification for having sanford here
this year is the very special story at
the mit department of architecture of a
constant dialogue between those inside
and outside architecture
and different kinds of creative realms
of course from kyogre keppes to the
spatial architectures of joan jonas to
our own azra akshamija the director of
the art culture and technology program
and artist and architect both here with
us tonight
it's part of
the special work we do here at mit and
the work that sanford will be
instrumental in shaping and influencing
this year
so with that i invite you to join us
again
next week for vernell noel
in a lecture uh hosted by the
computation group in our public lecture
series
titled situation computations craft and
technology and the title alone again
should tell us something about who we
are and what we do here so
thank you again sanford thank you again
audience here thank you audience outside
and audience online whose questions were
also part of the dialogue here tonight
good night and see you next week